let's talk now about normalization one
of the most important and relevant
concepts that we've talked about during
the current administration is the
realization that things that are not
normal are being normalized and hyper
normalized now some of this comes from
numbness humans adapt and things become
quote normal very quickly even things we
would not imagine would become normal
part of it is the Trump administration
working to normalize for example
corruption the way Trump insults people
the way Trump puts his family and
friends in positions of power and
privilege through his presidency Trump's
violations regularly of the emoluments
clause the weekly or sometimes almost
daily scandals with all of it we have to
work hard not to become numb and
desensitized to the insanity but also
the Trump administration wants to make
these things normal and the truth is it
works in part because humans adapt
incredibly well and very quickly and
outrageous situations become normal
seeming or normal feeling any one of
trumps scandals from just the last week
alone would have been months of coverage
if Barack Obama were president Trump's
Justice Department saying hey you know
what we're not gonna prosecute Michael
Flynn who already pleaded guilty by the
way that would have been an insane
scandal during the Obama administration
Trump's press secretary lying in an
unhinged way and cutting short briefings
holding 20-minute briefings that start
40 minutes late that would have been
three months on Fox News about the lack
of transparency and descend the the
constant dishonesty of an administration
Trump getting caught as I told you 10
minutes ago it's basic essentially
throwing out or suppressing the CDC's
actual reopening guidelines there are
others any one of those would have been
a month-long scandal for Barack Obama
but they are blips for Donald Trump but
the real normalization that is being
planned is make the coronavirus deaths
normal and frame it as
we're back in business we're reopening
everything's ok we have gotten past the
peak and things are good now and the
Trump administration has been hinting at
this for a long time with their entire
we never shut down because of the flu
stuff the Cure can't be worse than the
disease
were past the peak we've handled it well
things are improving the plan has been
for a while now just don't talk about
the virus itself anymore talk about
reopening talk about businesses talk
about CEOs talk about how we have
ventilators coming after the bleach
injection fiasco they essentially
stopped the normal press briefings and
replace them with propaganda events like
a CEO roundtable a day of prayer at the
White House later today or maybe earlier
today if you're listening in the evening
or tomorrow
Trump is finally doing a press briefing
but it will be to make a testing related
announcement no doubt more testing
propaganda and now again they are
talking about car crash deaths cancer
deaths suicide all things that of course
are not highly contagious and are not
communicable it is coordinated you've
got Republican senators using it Fox
News recently put up an image that
compares heart disease and cancer deaths
to those from coronavirus and meanwhile
the deaths keep climbing we've now
passed the 80,000 death mark remember
Trump was saying for a month or longer
we're gonna have 60,000 then when it was
clear we would have more he said we
could have 70 to 80 now he's talking
about ninety to a hundred most models
now are talking about a hundred and
thirty thousand during wave one so the
plan that now is the one being put in
place by this administration is just
pretend everything's fine they've failed
you look at other countries you look at
Italy Spain Germany France others their
curves actually make sense in the
context of dealing with the issue and
Trump has failed Trump has failed so
they are not going to talk about it they
will make it the status quo just like
listen people die in car accidents
people die of coronavirus could this
work it certainly can work for a while
the problem is that ignoring the virus
and the death
this leads to more of it because people
spread the disease
Trump's calculating that ignoring it and
inviting CEOs to the White House is
going to get them reelected in November
news channels presumably will continue
reporting the death numbers and Trump
can suppress it as much as he wants
eventually it's going to catch up with
him eventually as other countries open
their borders to countries that have
this under control but they keep their
borders close to the United States
Americans are going to realize I think
something will be wrong when Canadians
are allowed to fly to Germany and Brits
can fly to Japan but Americans aren't
allowed to fly anywhere you would
imagine that that will eventually have
an impact and by the way we still aren't
doing enough testing we are now getting
to 300,000 tests per day it's taken more
than two months to get there we need to
be at 500,000 a day as a minimum on
route to 1 million a day or 2 mil we are
just now approaching 300,000 tests a day
even the simpler things they're not
doing and so this is the new strategy
it's gonna be up to this up to us to
decide whether we fall for it whether
whether we allow it essentially because
even though we know that car crashes and
coronavirus deaths are not the same
thing takes a lot of work not to start
to become numb to many of these numbers
and of course everybody who is directly
affected by the virus is not going to
become numb to the numbers but a lot of
people are just in fantasy land they
don't know anyone who's died from the
virus and unfortunately for a lot of
these right-wingers until it affects
them personally it's just not real they
just don't care and it's gonna be up to
you and to me and to everybody else to
decide do we allow this to become the
norm or do we say this has been an
abject failure and this administration
must be removed five and a half months
from now that's how far away we are at
this point five and a half months let me
know what you predict I'm on twitter at
D Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blinka stinkiest lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video